Hello Freak bitches.
You know Tony cut a bunch of weight.
He figured it out with Tony was like
three pounds over like a couple days out.
Yeah, but like two weeks before Tony
goes down, he has it down to us.
He's a soldier dude. I mean,
but they don't fuck them.
But it also, if you're Dana,
you, you need more weight
classes cause it's fucking your,
your your business up because
it could be, I mean, yeah,
we can't put any money on them.
You can congress never going to find him.
He's not fighting Tony next. Tony
don't want to find him. Like, dude,
you came and mason away. Barboza
maybe who's going to five? Our buzzer,
a hib eat is, it could be a Bentley.
He's got according to and he's got a new
nutritionist and the nutritionist has
got him on point. Look, it's a discipline
issue. It's got to keep the Tiramisu,
Tiramisu. I don't give a fuck if, you
know, it's definitely a discipline issue,
but it's also a psychological issue. Do
you think Tony is going to fight? Conor,
you think that's going down?
I asked Conner make us host.
Conor made that post to Tony.
You know when you recently today he
made an instrument the GTA pose. Yeah.
Grand theft auto with him holding a
gun. Driving a boat. Cause Tony did it.
Cause Tony had at first, right? Well
Tony was talking shit about him.
He called the mcnugget and all that stuff.
Tony postings to shit.
But didn't Tony originally posted the
GTA a meme and then Connor responded with
his or vice versa. I think
it's vice versa. I think
Connor went out. Tony, look,
Connor smart, he realizes it. Tony's
a unusual eccentric character. Yeah,
you wrote Tony.
Conor is an unusual like has
got a bag of cash in the back.
Connors and unusual Accenture care. Tony's
and unusual Accenture character too.
And Tony,
Tony has the longest winning streak
in the UFC 155 pound division.
He is the interim champion and he's
the logical first one. 10 in a row.
For God sakes, in the toughest division
in the world. He's a bad motherfucker.
No doubt. Here's the problem at champion.
Here's the problem with that, and I,
I 100% think Connor
has to fight Tony next.
If you want to be taken serious and
your legacy, you have to fight Tony.
But if you're talking, if you're
Connor's business decision makers,
you're going look at Tony's
draw for paper view though.
It's can tough for us to
sell this thing. Well, yes,
but not with Connor Connor cells like
fucking crazy and controversies Tony cells
because Tony's a legit threat.
Connor versus my mom sells.
But Connor versus a legit threat cells
like Connor fighting, someone sells.
But controversies. Illegit threat is where
it gets interesting as the big fight.
That's the big fussy. All I, I
agree. It's only Julio. You kidding?
He's arrived everybody. He's a
character. Yeah, but Eddie, that's right.
But the pay per view numbers were fucking
terrible. Awful. They're terrible. Well,
well, you know, but don't get me
wrong, it takes two to tango. It does.
Not to Connor, but you can release isn't
the biggest name on a planet. He said,
everybody respects him in the game
because they know he's a beast.
He's coming up, fucking people up,
choking people out left and right.
They know he's a beast,
but the world really didn't know him yet.
You know what I mean?
The world doesn't know either of them.
And there was a lot of cultural learning.
Now the world knows Tony.
There was a lot of controversy and Kevin's
Tony for sure the whole world doesn't
know Tony,
but the MMA world now is Tony for sure.
But the regular people with the
people that you need to get ahold of,
nor to really buy paper views
because the world knows nay.
And that's where the businessman
does WMS go, well let's do Nate,
which if you look at any poll, I did
a pull air Hawaii to pull him junkie.
Everyone goes, no, Tony
first and the fucking fight.
You're talking hundreds of thousands
of votes. People go, Tony Ferguson,
the next fight, but is going,
yeah, put the money's over here.
But the nae fights not going anywhere.
And how long are you gonna let Connor
play this kind of weird makeup,
a fight game thing with Nate.
Nate made 4 million bucks over two
fights and he don't give a fuck.
He's like, pay me. You got to pay me.
He's going to pay for what you're,
you've lost for the last seven.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah. But he
beat Conner and then the second fight,
he arguably had a draw with Connor,
but he lost.
He lost a decision based on
a couple of people's opinion,
but I think if you went to all that
matters, Joe, but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't.
Public opinion means a lot.
If you went online and you ask
people who you think won that fight,
I bet you would get very close
to 50 50 Nate versus Connor.
Doesn't matter when Lassi man does matter
in terms of how you sell the fight.
It doesn't because to sell the
fight, if, if Nate would have won,
if those three people and having a
winning, you don't have a third fight
fight after he beat twice in a
row after we beat Eddie Alvarez,
you absolutely could have a third fight.
He absolutely especially beat them
twice. That's not true. Not True.
Especially if he beat
him by the same decision.
If the had the exact same fight
and Nate one that decision,
which was entirely feasible,
right?
The second fight was so close that you
could easily have given it to Nate.
If Nate wins that second fight, she's
build them twice in a row. You know,
think the, after Connor knocks
out Eddie Alvarez, the way he did,
if Connor fought Alvarez knocked him out,
you don't think you could sell a third
fight because it was so god damn razor
close. God. Oh,
and to I guess here you're looking at
the numbers and they see the problem with
decisions is these decisions are
solidified by three people that oftentimes
don't even have a fucking background in
MMA. Correct. Judges off all the time.
That doesn't mean a lot to me.
What it means a lot to me
is how close to fight was.
That's what means a lot to me.
If a guy goes over to see me,
touch somebody on the trilogy, what do
we Jamie and cards from that fight? Yeah.
47,
47484740840 seven that's his
fucking close as it gets.
It's a majority decision. One guy
scored it a draw, Glenn Trowbridge.
I do not remember what I thought,
whether I thought it was uh, uh,
went to Connor or went to, you know what?
I don't think I've watched it again.
I'm pretty sure I only watched that
fight when I was a close fucking fight.
Super Razor close.
We've seen decisions like in fights
that weren't as close go to the other,
but no one got robbed in that fight.
I wouldn't say Nate got robbed.
I say that it's a controversial decision
because anytime you have a majority
decision,
there's some controversy to it.
But my point is you could easily
sell that fight. Even if Connor,
even if needed one. I think
there's other sites, bigger fights.
If you know what is, what do you, what
does a bigger fight if Nate fought Conor,
you don't, you think there's a bigger
fight than that? If you're saying,
hold on Joe,
what are you trying to fight you?
So you're saying if Nate beat him twice,
the third fights can be the big fight.
Right now you see this beat him stuff.
It's the same exact fight. Okay.
The same exact fight takes place.
God Damn Man,
when they lose the same exact fight,
the same exact fight,
those three random fucking people,
they decide, you know what,
this 47 47 I'm going to go 48
47 Diaz and then the 48 47 goes.
You know what? I think it's the opposite.
I think it's 48 [inaudible] world.
It's not a make believe world cause it's
entirely feasible that that could ever
happen and Tony has Christ
and you listening to me,
it's entirely possible that that could
have happened in the exact same fight.
It's still the same fight.
The see the fight was very close.
Those guys were rivals, man in Nate
choked him the fuck out and the correct.
Right.
That's always going to be there.
So even if Connor like got real close,
Connor's such a superstar that if he
lost a close decision, the second fight,
you get absolutely.
Make an argument for third fight.
Especially with one or two spectacular
performances like the Eddie Alvarez.
So if we're going off that we can do
any fight. Let's, let's do Josie Aldo.
He could say, Oh that was a freak
accident. 13 seconds. Let's run that back.
That's a huge driver
for sure.
And then that's when Eddie Alvarez back,
if you'd be just the
thing about [inaudible],
he beat the shit out of Eddie
Alvarez and then knocked them out.
Eddie was never in that fight. All the
spring Chatman is back cause he did,
he took it on a six week, six
day notice. Sound a bad idea.
But Chad signed at one 45. You know
what I'm saying? You saying like why?
I don't understand what you're saying. I'm
just saying and uh, the, the Nate fight,
it could've gone either way, but that it
didn't happen. So you can make any color,
any fights can be big, but winning and
losing does matter than today to the,
to the general population, it
does matter. It does matter.
But when the fights are the exact same,
you could easily see the,
the decision go one way or
the other. Like, you know,
there's fights that you've watched
where you say, you know what,
the guy got the decision, but
man, I don't agree with it.
You just said that with Musashi for
sure. Man, that happens all the time.
That's part of the game. I look at that.
If I, if I look at a fight like that,
I absolutely want to see that fight again.
I don't care if one guy got a decision
from three people that don't agree with.
That's fine.
I guess we're kind of saying the same
thing I'm saying Amy fight Conor does is
going to be big. Well, the heat, any
fight context, then you can be big,
but I think we both agree that the big
money's in the Nate Diaz fight correct.
And fight to do the big money
would be in the Nate Diaz fight.
Even if they beat him in the second fight.
I really don't think so.
I disagree with you than I do because
I think Conor is a giant superstar.
He's not going to be less of a superstar
and I think Nate would be a bigger star.
How many times he kind of
leans towards more money.
If Nate beat him in the second fight,
I think Holly,
I think Nate would be a bigger star.
Tony and Conor is about his biggest fight.
You can get in the lightweight division.
Tony in UFC history in UFC history,
Tony against Connor,
and that's like Duran vs Leonard.
I don't think it's the biggest fight,
but I think it's,
it's up there.
It's what the among the best
lightweight a unification.
Connor's coming off of the
Floyd Mayweather hired. People
know. Let's say if Nate,
first of all, any before you rip my
head off, I agree. Tony and Conor,
100% he's a star in our world,
in the pot,
in the big world. He's
not. He's a star. Two Star,
let's say,
may hold on a second.
You think you can go to the gas
station right now and go, hey man,
who's Tony Ferguson? It depends on
the guy who's there. They'll know
WWE shirt,
shirt on and off.
You go to the average person
and asked them who Nate Diaz is.
Way more people going to know who he
is. Then Tony, now, now hear me out.
Joe Floyd Mayweather.
There's a still a bigger name.
Then they could do that.
They could do a rematch and have
another bid five bigger than Kukui,
but I'm talking about for the UFC.
Fuck everyone outside the UFC.
UFC has millions and millions of funding.
It's a bigger name all over the world.
All over the world. There's
the, he has the interim belt.
He has to fight him. I
know there's a discussion,
right? As in terms of like as
a purist, correct. But Joe,
what if this was another fight? Ufc
Fan? I'm right. As your average UFC fan,
what if Nate fought Barboza
or Khabib and beat them?
Think how big that Nate fight would be
with Connor. Then that's a big if though,
the problem with that is Nate's lost.
We're talking about it. If world,
right now we're talking,
we're not, or loss of time up,
but we're not right now because we're
talking about what the pieces are in play
right now. Like what? Wait, what
do we have right in front of,
so we're going to do right now. So
if you're doing it right now, well,
if you're going by what
the fans have voted,
Tony would be the fight
that the pure SWOT,
but this is the fans that
listen to Ariel Helwani or you.
These are hardcore people.
In order to make money,
you have to get those people and then
you've got to get the people who know it
peripherally. Well then Nate Diaz, we
Pauline [inaudible] the next fight,
they don't even know Polly melon out. How
dare you? They don't until he fights it.
Unless Connor fights in boxing. That's
what I'm saying. Yeah, but I mean, well,
if taken all that out of context,
Nate is the bigger fight.
No matter how we paint this picture.
The re the fight you should do.
Is Tony though, do you think that
Paulie Malignaggi versus Connor,
Tony New sunglasses,
do you think that Pauline mile and
algae versus Connor is a bigger fight in
boxing then Nate versus Connor is an MMA?
I think whatever Connor does is, is
big. It doesn't matter. Doesn't matter.
I think Nate versus Connor is bigger in
MMA then Paulie versus Connor is boxing.
Yeah.
Because,
because Paulie's not like
a Floyd Mayweather where
he's going to get all those
boxing fans. Paul was good and
he's a big names on showtime,
but he's not Floyd
Mayweather. The big, yeah,
the whole Nate fricking fan base.
You have to Connor fan base,
then you have dubby WME behind
that with the hype machine.
They've severely lightened that.
What a sanctions on weed. Yeah, but,
but if you're WME, you're going, what are
we going to make the [inaudible] knife?
You're WME. If you're commerce
business planners, you're going,
how do we make the most money?
It's a McGregor promotion in boxing.
We're gonna make more money doing that.
Fighting Polly.
And it's safer than fighting
Nate. We're fighting Tony. True.
But if Connor loses two
in a row and boxing,
that's the most severely
diminishes his star in Him.
It may come watch MMA and by the way,
they'll strip him of his belt.
If he fights another, we got a strip
up. They ain't doing shit to him.
He does USC. Who's going to do
it? He does whatever he wants.
He might find it heavyweight if
you want to do that. I can do shit.
To me it's too much of a drawl. But
Tony or Nate, is it dangerous fight?
Either fight, is it Tony? Tony, Tony,
and Nate are more dangerous
than fighting poly.
One of the did his own GTA post.
What does it say?
Does it say anything? There's no
comment. I don't think monument.
What does that count? Yeah, just that.
Okay.